I am the danger a guy opens his door and
gets shot and you think out of me
I am the one who knocks
I couldn't find Walter White's emotional
core and I was struggling and then all
of a sudden it hit me it's calloused
over
he doesn't even know what it is it's a
rock in his in his soul
[Music]
Breaking Bad
and you got one part of that wrong
that's
is not meth I will say this up front
that the Lion's Share of Walter White
was really the imagination of Vince
Gilligan he's genius and he laid out a
beautiful template for me to step in I
remember going to my wife I always get
her counsel because
we're together we whatever I do affects
her so I wanted to get her input on it
and I said to her
um just know that
this show would shoot in Albuquerque New
Mexico
if it were to happen and I handed her
the script and she started reading the
script and I would peek in to see every
once in a while she was like boom boom
boom boom boom to the end right once you
got near the end I came back into the
room
and she went
she just said and I knew that was
her approval chemistry is
well technically
chemistry is the study of matter
but I prefer to see it as the study of
change now just
think about this I started out that
character very uh Meek very you know
submissive and passive a pushover
because he he didn't know who he was he
and that's why then once I got that I
went oh he should be a little overweight
the love handles he should be pasty
white he should have a mustache that
looks like you know either grow one or
cut it one or the other yeah and then
and then I called it an impotent
mustache and I know how how to shape an
impotent mustache if anyone's interested
if a mustache drops below the creases of
the of the lips no that gets badass that
gets nasty so you have to make sure
that's always above the crease of the
lips and you thin it out so you can see
skin underneath it and it doesn't look
as masculine it just seems what's the
point I was always looking for those
what's the point and my I chose my
clothes in conversations with the
costume designer to select clothes that
blend in the wall beige is awful flights
pastels soft yellows things like that
sand color anything he didn't he
disappeared he was a nobody I took all
the color highlights out of my hair
which I had it was kind of brown with
with kind of reddish highlights took it
all out just deadened it took the color
out of my face you know all of a sudden
you start to see yourself and you put on
those clothes you go
I know you
let's go play WWE
I mean who you figure that is huh Walter
White
okay
you got me
if success and fame and celebrity never
came I'd be fine because I was making a
living I was doing what I love to do and
I had a great family so it was okay now
all of a sudden this happens and you you
have to learn how to deal with it
because you're you're not ever taught
how to become a celebrity
how to handle yourself as a famous
person it's almost like when you become
a a parent for the first time you just
have to trial an error had Malcolm in
the Middle been picked up for an eighth
season someone else would have played
Walter White because I would not have
been available but that summer is when I
first read
uh his script Vince's script for
Breaking Bad
[Music]
Malcolm in the Middle
name to just dump this in the trash
maybe Birds would like to make nests
with it or I don't know maybe you boys
could use it for school projects
arms up
dude I came up with a philosophy
um that I is the most important thing
that I try to extend to younger
generations of actors and that is you're
not going into an audition trying to get
a job you're going there to do a job
hold your power and then give it to them
and allow them to take it and do what
they will with it those decisions about
who might get a job or not or not for
you to decide so don't waste an ounce
thinking about that I was testing for
three Pilots all comedies I had this
philosophy so I wasn't worried and then
another one comes up for fox called
Malcolm in the Middle
who wants to make five bucks how I need
someone to take the fall oh my God make
a ten
son
stop playing off of this bombastic
aggressive woman Lois don't compete with
her do not try to match her
so I started to think what would be a
complimentary
characteristic for Hal would be perhaps
the opposite of her what is she lacking
oh she's lacking subtlety softness
sweetness quiet she's so I won't she's
fearless so I'm fearful of everything
and I just started putting these out and
I went oh that's a character I'm
developing a character here so I just
let it all sit within him and the last
bit was no one wants to see a person
who's indifferent to their family who
who can care less or whoever is doing
whatever so I I made a distinction that
Hal was not
disinterested in his family he was
distracted
buy things and I love the fact that we
were a married couple and my character
was madly in love with his wife it was a
nice thing to see on television
well I was naked and covered in blue
paint I was strapped to the front of a
moving bus I was hung upside down and
tortured I had ten thousand honeybees on
me at one time so it just went on and on
and on they said what would you do I
learned how to roller skate and did a
roller skating episode it was just a
glorious time because who gets to do
that I got to play I I went to work to
play I first proposed the idea of a of a
reunion movie the creator of the show
Linwood Boomer is warming to it if we
come across an idea that that all of us
feel is really valid not just I have no
interest to do keep busy or pick up a
paycheck I want to do something that man
that's a great idea and we get to see
these people 20 years later you know all
the boys are now in there at least in
their 30s they're all grown men married
children you know old it's just an
extraordinary situation for me I was in
fact a couple of them are nearing the
age I was when I played the dad of those
kids
[Music]
Seinfeld
is a jury Seinfeld hey you didn't come
with us uh Tim the pencil Jerry hey Tim
Jerry I didn't think it'd show did you
say Jerry I didn't think you'd show or
Jerry I didn't think you'd show the
audition for Seinfeld was great did it
first for the casting director Meg
Lieberman and then for the call back
Jerry was in the room and the goal of
any actor is to man if I can get him to
laugh
that's the thing and I got him
that was funny and then they called me
back and they call me back and again and
again and again and again and pretty
soon you're you have a recurring role on
that and I look different on each
episode because I went off and did other
things and so I had a beard I didn't
have a beard I had long hair had short
hair I had a crew cut I had a mustache
you know it's fun the life of an actor
and they never they never bothered
explaining why does Whatley look so
different every time we see it the
Precision in which Jerry and Larry would
craft a joke or a moment a beat was just
awe-inspiring and of course Julia and
Jason and and Michael were brilliant
brilliant Comedians and so no matter who
was acting in any scene at any given
time I'm watching Brilliance so even if
I only had two scenes in something I'm
watching the rest of the show all
through rehearsal all through taping
nights just to be there to soak it up
your honor
Where Have You Been counselor I'm sorry
you're on sure but you were also late
yesterday morning so what's the answer
to my question
I have a problem getting out of bed in
the morning your honor is something that
got me with the concept of the first
season which was as a parent myself
being asked what would you do to save
the life of your child and the answer
that any parent would answer as far as I
know is anything
I would do anything the follow-up
question as I started to get into the
character was
would I become a criminal if I really
felt that by doing so I would protect my
child yep yep I would become a criminal
and that's the story of Michael desiado
in in your honor and actors in general
are are novices at at everything except
playing other people
so when whenever we start a a character
it's always outside of us
and you need to trust that through work
and through your ability and through
your imagination
and your availability of your emotional
treasure chest
uh you'll be able to put it all together
first season ended tragically so the
second season we flip it and it becomes
about a man exploring despair when
tragedy strikes
it it has a ripple effect on many people
around
not just the immediate family but that
first Inner Circle then the second and
third people that you work with if you
worked with someone who lost a child
that relationship is going to change and
I hope that when people watch this who
are experiencing that particular
condition or have maybe perhaps they're
they're curious to see how one person
handles it and make adjustments in their
life to see if there is a life beyond
tragedy
Drive
director wants to see a rollover you
okay with that
remember if you don't feel good just
abort the shot there's no shame in that
all right
you're doubling for the start you know
like a day play or anything
and I got you 500 more huh
of course we split that
you okay ready to go all right Ryan's
character has a he was a thoughtful man
and a you know an expert driver and he
wasn't very talkative and so I thought
well I think it would be kind of
interesting to to counter that that I'm
a bit too talkative and also it made
sense because a person who's too
talkative often talks themselves into
trouble says something they shouldn't
have said does something they shouldn't
have done and that's what my guy was he
was just you kind of want to slap him
and go just shut the hell up sometime
will you
calm down I can build a car in six
months and in six seconds these jerks
write it off as a stunt that won't even
make it into the movie
see all I need is a hard used stock car
that's all now I figure we start off
with a small town circuit and we work
our way up stunt coordinators and
stuntmen in general are Rough and Tumble
They're a bit crazy and they'll probably
even tell you that themselves to do what
they do the broken bones the abrasions
the contusions that they get in doing
their work every single day and so I
thought
um I thought this guy was a tough kid
probably a kid who jumped off his roof
being a space man you know jumped off
balconies into pools when he was a
teenager things like that he was the guy
watch this he's that guy you know and so
I I said I I think he's from a
Midwestern town so I made him from you
know the Chicago area and I put the hard
R in there and he's just one of those
guys it said he had a had a limp and and
I wanted it to make it uh germane to his
life and so I I pitched that Ron
Pearlman character that he did it to me
make it specific so we have to deal with
him again and he's I don't like this guy
take a hike I want to talk to my
partner
I haven't just with you
how you doing Shannon how's the
like
I paid my debt
I'll think about it the character that
Albert Brooks played he and I loved each
other too he he really had an affinity
for me I think in the original script he
came behind me with a garretting wire
and had and choked me that's a very
violent death to be choked right it's
you know it's you have to have someone
behind you and it's like you have to
have this aggressive move and there's
something that just didn't it just
didn't feel right and Anna was bugging
me I'll let it go I let it go and one
one night I had this dream and I woke up
in the middle of the night going
oh my God I got it I got it I got it oh
my God oh my God oh my God do you know
where the handshake came from the
handshake came from showing you have no
weapon I show you we may not know each
other but I show you we have no weapon
and out of that came the clasp to say I
don't have a weapon either and two men
with no weapons can say Okay truce peace
right I said what if I see him in my
garage and we're like oh and I'm not
quite sure and but he's talking very
casually
and he's talking like I'm sorry this
worked out this way it just didn't it
didn't work out that you know it's the
way it goes but hey I hope you hope you
I wish you well you know kind of thing
and he holds out his hand and I'm like
oh maybe he's gonna let me go
oh great and that handshake and as soon
as I touch his hand he turns my wrist
with his other hand comes out a knife
and he slices my arm and I'm in shock
and then immediately he starts to put me
at ease to assuage my fears to to not
let me drop but lower me down caress my
head against the bumper not let me hit
it and and just kind of
comfort me it's gonna be okay it's gonna
be okay and
I pitched that and there and Nicholas is
going that's in the movie
we're gonna do that that's in the movie
because he had the thought of making
Albert Brooks's character a knife
collector anyway and he was said this is
so perfect for him to do in his milieu
his way of doing it and um and that's
how that's how I I died
[Music]
Saving Private Ryan he's two men died in
Normandy
this
man at Utah
Peter Ryan this man was killed last week
in New Guinea
[Music]
Daniel
Ryan well whenever you get an
opportunity to work for an auteur an
artist the level of Steven Spielberg you
don't hesitate you you you accept that
call and you do whatever they want and
my arm was straight down in my pants
when it was shooting from behind and
when I'm shooting from front it was I
held it like that even rehearsing is
that I had no movement here I can't pull
it out because the uniform you know
we're doing take after take so I just
kept my hand
confined you have to experience what
that's like so I was well prepared I
took a demitos cup and saucer and the
saucer fit right in there and I had a
demitas spoon that I would stir my
coffee and I poured it I picked it up I
stirred my coffee dink dink tap the edge
of it put it on the on the saucer itself
rotate the hand to the to hold the
saucer and then put it down on my desk
all without looking and
I was so excited and I and finally we're
going to shoot my scene Stephen and the
whole crew comes in and I go Stephen I
have an idea he goes you do I said yes I
said and I showed him the whole thing
you know and I poured the coffee put it
down interested in this document this is
this is really important stuff here and
I picked up the thing and put a sugar in
it's a sir stir Tata and he was like
amazed he went oh my God that's really
good I can't use it I said oh
I said oh really he goes yeah he said
because at this moment
we know what's happened we've got to get
the news up the ranks to the general to
make the decision so as soon as the
scene starts I'm following the captain
who's got this paper we've got to get
Private Ryan out and he's coming right
to me and he right to my desk and I read
it and I go where'd you get this and you
know and we got to see the general we
get up and go see the general it's not a
loss it was I got a chance to act I got
a chance to create a moment even though
the moment was Never filmed
all the way
all I have
I would have given gladly not
to be standing here today
the greatest leader of our time
has been struck down I went down to the
Johnson library in Austin Texas two
different times and had access to
whatever I needed and my own personal
security guard the library is closed
everyone else and they said just you
know when you want to leave he'll open
it up and lock it into the land oh great
so I'm just absorbing as much as I can
so I was most interested in in trying to
see if I can understand the 36th
president of the United States Lyndon
Baines Johnson and and it took a long
time to to come in so I was full hyper
focused on that and for some reason I
just thought oh yeah I'll get to the
lines and stuff at some point and I and
I I felt like I started to get them I I
got a sense of him I got his Cadence
down and his his draw down and um his
his sensibility and his heart and his
meaning is ambition and his relation to
him
it was starting to feel really good and
really confident oh I have to get going
now because we have three weeks to
rehearse it's a three-hour play and my
character speaks
for almost all of it and we're making
history here Everett and you have to
decide how you want history to remember
you I'm off stage maybe a total of four
minutes the rest of the three hours is
me speaking and all of a sudden we did a
table read and I panicked I made a
calculable error and that was
oh my God I neglected the logistics the
balance of learning lines to the point I
even fantasized about someone jumping me
in my lowest of low someone jumped me
and beat me up
and I I got put into the hospital which
delayed the opening of the that's how
bad it was I was so nervous I was so
scared because I was not going to be
ready my dear friend Bill timoney an
actor great in his own right I hired him
to come and stay in the in the second
bedroom and drill those lines in me just
go over and over morning noon and night
several times I'd wake up and there'd be
sheets of of dialogue just in my face
you know Bill gave me some great wisdom
he said just here's the bottom line he
said on opening night you are going to
be on that stage and you are going to do
this play
so up until that point
we just keep working
I was like I needed to hear that you
know once you get it and I did I I was
on stage and I never missed a
performance and you know eight shows a
week three hours per day you know it's
like wow man bang bang bang doing
theater from an actor's standpoint is
far more exhausting than doing long
hours on a movie or a television show it
was in the bones by then
it was in the bones by the time we made
the movie all the way